for
e
good evening everyone welcome to this
extraordinary scrutiny panel
meeting uh run through the safety
procedures if the fire alarm is
activated please vacate the offices down
the main staircase opposite the lifts in
the foyer assemble in hly square on the
green officers will assist you and
advise you when it's safe to return to
the chamber would everyone present
please ensure their mobile phones are
turned to silent and they are not used
to make or receive phone calls whilst
the meeting is in progress uh please
note this meeting is being live streamed
for members of the public the meeting is
also recorded and will be subsequently
forcast on the internet does anyone
intend to film the
meeting that's no so we'll move on and
there's no members of the public so
we'll move on to the next one okay
speaking under 20% .1 we've had requests
from councelor Joan brght wants to speak
under item five and councelor Jill
bayford who wants to speak under item
three uh public speaking I've had a
requests from Miss Ruth Bailey who wants
to speak under item six moving on to
apologies I've received apologies from
councelor Wing who's substituted by
councelor Garner uh councelor green
who's subse substituted by councelor
scobby Will scobby and uh Miss councelor
Moore who's replaced by councelor
manners are there any more
apologies and that's a no so are there
any Declarations of
Interest that's a no okay moving on to
item three uh the ret tiering of the
responsive repairs contract I will call
on Miss CIO Sullivan to introduce the
report thank you chair um this report is
regards ing our proposed approach
approach to the procurement of a
partnering contractor for day-to-day
responsive repairs voids compliance and
Major Works this is a service that is
currently provided by Mir the contract
is due to expire on the 31st of March
2025 due to the size and complexity of
this contract we must start the process
now to ensure we give ourselves enough
time to apply the right model and to
procure the right partner to deliver
this
service we have sought the assistance of
a consultant to help us get this right
the consultant we have chosen has worked
extensively with local authorities
across Kent to procure the same kind of
contract meaning they have a wealth of
experience to apply to this
process we have carried out a series of
workshops where we discussed what's
working well and what we want to improve
with our current service and have
explored different options for our
approach to Service delivery with our
new
contract we kept a strong focus on local
delivery and the employment of local
operatives
as part of this we looked at the option
to bring the entire service inh housee
and this was discarded due to a number
of operational issues that would hinder
setup and smooth Service delivery these
included not having a Depot available to
work out of store plants and materials
and would take a substantial investment
and time to set up requirement for
additional management for finance and
ICT the ability to cope with Peaks and
troughs of work through seasonal demand
and we would still have have to procure
contractors to carry out specialist
works for example aspros management and
electrical
safety this is discussed more
extensively in 3.12 of this
report we decided that the best proposal
was to rework and improve the current
model which is a price per property and
price per void this means we have a
fixed price agreement per property which
through our service provider will carry
out repairs and maintenance using the
National schedule of rates for anything
that Falls outside the main benefits of
this model include less Administration
than if we were to approve individual
schedule of rates for all jobs and voids
officers can focus on quality of Works
rather than value we can have faster
repair completion as this model means
that the contractor can complete works
without seeking authorization from TDC
for a majority of orders and this is a
familiar way of working for TDC
officers the main disadvantage is that
contractors may try and charge in
appropriately for repairs they deemed
fall outside the price per property
model or carry out Works in a property
so the value of final value Falls
outside the price cap we will write
elements into the contract to mitigate
against these risks and this includes
including a clear document that sets out
what repairs are included within the
price per property and price per void
setting an appropriate cap to the price
per property clearly defining what
happens when works go above the set cap
we are Keen to extend the provision of
some of our in-house services and this
would include minor Works fencing and
arborous works while we do this we
intend to keep these services available
to call off through this contract as
well and this provides resilience to the
service to our
residents we have sought to include an
element in into this procurement by
introducing a requirement for a bid and
delivery partner as a separate lot this
means we could have two partnering
contractors one for the main element for
delivering repair and maintenance and
one to be a delivery partner for Grant
funded
works we know that when grant funding
becomes available we have to be ready to
bid for it and often deliver Works
within a very tight time frame and we
have included an estimated spend of 4
million per year for this element but
this will not be spent unless grant
funding is available and our P partner
delivers a winning bid
application I have have included this
level of spending because we are
ambitious and want the best for our
assets and our residents when grant
funding becomes available I want us to
be in the best position to be awarded
funding and deliver on what we said we
would do we have engaged our residents
in the formation of this proposal and
they as they have valuable firsthand
experience of this service our residents
gave some beneficial feedback and
endorsed the model
proposed we continue to engage our
residents in this process by asking them
to assist us with the analysis of
tenders that we receive thank you I
welcome any
questions uh thank you s uh councelor
wer do you wanted to speak as Cen
member thank you chair apologies
everyone my voice isn't great at the
moment if it sounds really
squeaky the level of work that goes into
both procurement and organization of a
housing service of this scale is
extraordinary as is the progress that
has been made within housing since we
brought it back in
house I am on occasion criticized for
being too ambitious in relation to
housing my confidence and belief in our
new acquisition strategy and my
willingness to invest in order to
produce social and affordable housing at
a far greater rate than ever before is
one area where some members believe I
may be too willing to invest I obviously
disagree but my ambition is informed by
knowledge and an understanding of both
procurement and risk and I will never
approve a strategy or approach that I
think could endanger either housing or
our ability to deliver
Services I am measured where I need to
be specifically to support greater
Ambitions for this portfolio and our
ability as a council
overall this contract was last extended
in
2020 it cannot be extended further which
means that coming in this may as an
Administration gives it luse an extended
in-house service across all areas much
as as evidenced by my determination to
bring housing back and produce in-house
temporary housing and our first in-house
sleeping rust sleeping accommodation my
general inclination is to create and
promote in-house Services wherever
possible ideals much as my brain
dislikes it have to be considered in
relation to realities and the security
of service especially when what is at
stake is the quality of delivered
service to a very large number of our
residents and as such focusing on areas
that we can deliver inhouse such as
minor works and ensuring that our Comm
complex and specialist areas function
and deliver without interruption is
essential as referenced in the report we
are now choosing to focus heavily on the
local economy in housing procurement our
contracts prioritize local jobs local
call centers and include the requirement
for local apprenticeships to build not
only the local economy but also build
skills and employment
opportunities this combined with our
proposed in-house expansion of minor
Works to explore our our delivery of
Direct Services allows us to deliver not
only many highly complex work streams
but also build our own resilience and
the sheer scale of the number of new
strategies being implemented and the
considerable growth of our portfolio
means that ensuring reliability of
provision at a time when we are still a
council with disproportionately low
Staffing for the scale of what we
deliver means that considering the
long-term future of all projects is
essential and testing the water in terms
of inh provision is a vital part of this
I know the level of work that has gone
into the preparation of this procurement
exercise and I recognize just how hard
Mr Sullivan and the team have worked I
welcome any discussion and any questions
and I am open as always to any
suggestions thank you chair thank you
councelor wated uh call on jel
bford thank you chair i' just like to
ask thank you Sally for the report I'd
just like to ask um what is the process
and criteria for um deciding to um
continue to contract beyond the 10 years
thank
you thank you um so the thought behind
that is this this is a a really large
task um and it takes a lot of work to
get to get through this this kind of
procurement it's it's very large it's
very complex so the time in that goes
into it needs to be kind of have the
rewards come out the other side um the
other side of the other part of this is
that this is a partnering contract and
partnering and Alliance is the key to
delivering the good service here um with
this kind of contract with a repairs and
maintenance contract particularly um a
long-term contract is more desirable and
favorable by the contractors that would
bid for that and it gives us that
opportunity to build that service
together in true partnership and form
that Alliance to give the best service
that we
can thank you so under what
circumstances would you not
continue um if we if we had a difficult
Partnership if the service provision was
not as we expected um and we were unable
to turn that around that would be a
reason to not continue for the further 5
years um also if we did explore further
the to bring that to bring the service
inhouse and that was uh a model that we
wanted to go ahead with then of course
there would be no reason to extend that
beyond the 10 years as
well okay
members hands up uh Council aimus
first thank you chair and thank you
Sally I've got two questions the first
one is um under item 3.7 where you've
got the thing about adding retrofit for
decarbonization into the contract could
you just unpack that bullet point a
little bit is it about somebody who can
provide bid writing specifically about
decarbonization is it about somebody who
can provide the physical works for
decarbonization and the bid writing or
could those be all be separated out I'm
not quite clear about that one and then
the other one was about how does the um
how does the model that you're using
using the the per property model work in
relation to the work with the other
Council departments how do you sort of
how do you decide that kind of uh aspect
of the work um I I see there are
allocations for other Council
departments but I'm not quite clear how
how that would work in relation to the
the per property stuff thank
you thank
you um so if I address your first
question councelor Austin
um so in regard to the retrofit for
decarbonization we we we are looking for
a bid and delivery partner that could
write the bid for us they would model
our data write the bid for us and if
they were successful with that bid on
our behalf um they would then go on to
deliver the work so it's a full package
and the reason we have done it that way
is um actually because as we have found
out with the social housing decard
funding that we did recently for the tow
blocks we were awarded the funding and
then we have 2 years to deliver the
amount of work to spend 9 months
procuring someone that can deliver the
work really puts in Jeopardy the ability
to be able to spend um so that's the
reason we've done that um a further
thought to this was that I'd probably
quite like to extend that to be able to
bid for any kind of grant funding that
came up and not keep it narrowed down
specifically to decarbonization works I
thought that might be of benefit to us
if we don't know what's going to come up
in the
future um the second point And in
regards to the other Council departments
there is provision in there in there for
them to call off on this contract and
that is entirely what it is it's an
ability to call off for Works they
require and this would be um using the
schedule of rates the price per property
is only for the social housing stock
yeah thank you Council
Patman yeah thank you chair um I got two
questions the first one is about um
when our supply chains or contractors
get it wrong TDC feel the the full whack
of that as in we get the complaint we
get the blame etc etc is there an
opportunity in these contracts or
renders to kind of have them more
accountable for their mistakes or for
their errors that's my first question
the second question is they also access
a lot of our residents homes that we
don't have access to or we will never
ever engage with is there a um referral
pathway for these Supply chains or or
contractors to raise safe guardians or
concerns uh when they enter the
properties thank
you thank you um okay so uh your first
question when when they get it wrong
when they make mistakes that of course
does happen we have um the ability
through our contract to Performance
manage our
contractor um and they are held they are
held accountable for that um in some
cases they will be required to take the
full responsibility for the stake
mistake they have made and respond to a
complaint um or to provide compensation
where that is appropriate um and like
I've said if there is a continuation of
core performance we will monitor that
through the um through the contract and
if it does go horribly wrong we of
course do we can terminate um we do have
break Clause that means we can terminate
for poor performance after a period of
monitoring and allowing them giving them
the opportunity to perform
better um and the second question is
regarding contractor's ability to raave
safeguarding concerns yes absolutely um
I feel like this is achieved through um
a true partnership as we'll be working
together to serve our residents
ultimately um contractors will always
have the ability to speak to us to raise
a concern but they also have access to
the council's um safeguarding to be able
to raise raise a safe guarding concern
through the website if they feel that is
more
appropriate thank you Council
menis thank you Sally thank you chair um
I'm a little bit concerned that we seem
to be well there's three three questions
really here um one is regarding value
for money um one is regarding timing and
the other is um on whether alternatives
to this have been properly examined or
whether we're being coralled into this
because of the time restraints
um on the value for money um I'm seeing
a headline figure of 11 million a year
uh over 3,400 properties uh the these
are all Residential Properties are
they okay so that that gives us about
3,200 just over 3,200 per property per
year um I do have some experience of the
private sector I uh in in my previous
earlier career um and I am I'm a land
with 15 or 16 houses and apartments and
when I look at the typical costings for
annual maintenance including leasehold
service charges and so on on leasehold
properties it's nearer 16,700 a year in
the private sector um so I just wondered
how we have a figure that's almost well
close on double that that's the first
part so should I should we do should we
go through the whole lot um second ly on
the timing of this
um it does seem that we're being uh as
Helen White header said that we're we're
up against the clock on this one in
which case have options been looked at
to roll this contract over for a further
year if it's all set up for a long-term
contract then um I would imagine that
having it roll over for a further year
whilst we properly examined all other
options um would would be plausible if
not desirable in fact so that's the
second question and thirdly um looking
at alternative business models for
managing this portfolio I mean it's a it
is a huge portfolio by any standards but
it's not unusual there are there are
quite a few operators in in the UK who
are managing in the private sector
managing substantially larger portfolios
than this um and it is possible to when
I look at the objection s that have been
given for um wanting to have this with
one
contractor uh rather than bringing this
more
inhouse um they're basically the all the
functions that a day-to-day portfolio
manager would have um
the when when you look at when you when
you slice it down in the private sector
you would expect around about 100 to 120
units to be under one property manager
um with a range of property inspectors
and um a preapproved stable of trusted
vetted contractors to undertake the
various roles and then the Professional
Service the legal and the uh surveying
services that that can be brought in um
under contract and I just wondered
whether that had been properly examined
because the evidence in the private
sector is that that would deliver far
better value or ought to deliver far
better value than we're seeing for the
£3,200 a unit that's being proposed here
thanks thank you that's a lot of
questions right um on the first one in
regards to value per money
um 11 million per year is not
realistically what we would spend
through this contract there is the
ability to spend that if if we need it
so um already 4 million per year is put
aside for the bid and delivery partner
and that will only be used if there is
funding available and if they are
successful with writing a bid through
which um the intention would be it would
be a minimum of 50% um outl lay for the
h um budget because we would hope the
50% would be covered by grant
funding there was also provision in
there for 2 million for Capital works
and again this is on a callof basis we
wouldn't necessarily spend 2 million
pound per year on Capital works but if
we did spend 22 million per capital
Works through this contract it wouldn't
be spent through another contract and we
would weigh that up as we go through to
see which would provide us better value
for money I've put that provision in
there because what we have experienced
since taking the um the stock in house
is um health and safety issu have come
up quickly and we have to respond to
them quickly um and these are structural
problems which are costly to repair um
and therefore to have that provision
through this contract to just be able to
go please go out and sort this out um
kind of answers that for us um so there
there already is is6 million which is
not is is added in because it needs to
be added into the contract and it needs
to be figured through the budget but
it's not necessary that we would spend
that each year so and and then there's
the small provision there for the uh
Capital Works um for the sorry the
corporate side of things as well which
which wouldn't be spent through our
price per property model so that kind of
brings it down much more in line to the
figures that you were talking about can
I can I come back on yes please yes um
two questions really what what um what
do you mean by Capital works I mean is
that um could you give an example of of
that within a in a in a specific
property um so uh currently we have we
have a property out there which we've
discovered recently has um very the
basically the windows are are almost
falling in and for many years they've
been held up with planks of wood which
this poses our immediate health and
safety issue and one that we want to
address as quickly as possible and those
are the kind of works that I'm talking
about we have price for that that's
going to cost about £44,000 because of
the structural works that have to be
carried out to make that property safe
and to repair whatever has been
happening with that okay um yeah on on
that I mean that's the sort of thing
that would be costed in on the, 1600 to
2,000 a year that I referred to in in
the private sector you would expect that
that includes things I mean examples
I've had is where um entire walls
exterior walls have had to be
reappointed um we've got one case where
we had £10,000 where uh uh a marine war
was actually subsiding we had to have a
new WF built and the hund and something
lease holders all got hit with a quite a
exceptional bill so I had costed that in
into the into the numbers there um what
is a bottom line figure then that you
would expect to actually be spending
under this
contract I'm going to find that really
difficult wind yeah I'm going to find
that really difficult to provide you off
the top of my head can I just can I come
back to you on that yeah thank you
sorry I don't want to make something up
okay councelor
Bri
hello I thought he was going to come
back later
sorry two other points on on the timing
the timing whether we're being coralled
could this um could this existing
contract be rolled over for a further
year to give us a breathing space and
I'll be faster with this one um so
unfortunately not the we can't extend
this contracts any further um and if we
did try to do that that would I believe
go against procurement regulations so we
do we can't extend it any further and we
do need to procure for this now in time
for a new contract coming in in
2025 and for the final
question I've lost it sorry um
alternatives proper ex looking
at um so we we did with with our um
consultant we did carry out a series of
workshops I wasn't part of all of them
and they did explore the
various um models that that we could
adopt for this um this was seen as um
the best model for us to go for in the
position that we are in now um because
it did provide um resilience for the
service
um to be able to continue to provide the
day-to-day repairs um like you have
pointed out that we don't have time and
you might feel coralled into doing this
we wouldn't have time to set up a DLo in
a year and a half um I I feel personally
that it would take at least 3 years for
us to start from scratch to prepare for
that kind of service to be brought
inhouse and to be able to do it properly
um
so I I think that we've gone for the the
best option that we can here and there
is an intention throughout the course of
this contract to explore what other
elements of work we can bring in house
um while the contract is going going
through there are elements of it that
are call off and we'll keep it that way
purposefully so that we can stop if need
be and we have we are happy with the
service that we can provide ourselves we
can then stop that coming through our
main contractor and just provide that
part for ourselves so we can almost do
that incrementally it's a feels like a
much safer option to go for in that
way thank thanks Sy uh
I I'm not comfortable obviously with it
feeling that we have been crowed into
this but but nobody you know time is
time um but if it is possible to develop
um in parallel in-house um Services
whilst this contract is underway if
there's any way that we can do that
under this contract then that would be a
good a good idea idea perhaps to to
consider simply because it then gives us
options um and we're not beholden to one
monopolistic supplier yeah
thank it's okay if I come back on that
chair um yeah we are um as evidence in
the report already looking to do that
with minor works so that we can build
capacity there which will obviously help
in other areas also because minor Works
spans a huge number of our functions
um that seems to me to be a very good
starting point for us to look at how
well that works and where we can expand
it to in other areas we discussed
earlier adding this to the housing CAG
um timetabling so that we can explore
what works um and what we see happening
in the long-term
future and what looks promising on that
front so that's something that will be
brought in fairly shortly thank
you okay councelor
Bri almost forgot what I was going to
ask them just the 12 questions for me um
I would really just I I don't come from
a property background um but deal with
contracts and things so I'm just curious
to see what kind of crossover there is
obviously it's encouraging that we are
um we're aiming to have a a long
contract and and a partnership um so
kind of ties into Jack's councelor
Pacman's question um around how the
contract is structured is there an
element of performance related pay going
on here where maybe they have to the the
contractor will have to deliver to
certain pricing commitments and either
on day on you know year one year two
they get x% of their fee either way
depending on how well they on how well
they
deliver thank you thank thank you for
the one question um that's not something
that we have considered putting into
this contract um but I I will take that
back to our consultant and and see if it
is worth considering um I think that we
have steered away from this because with
an element of performance related pay um
it can be
quite it's it's quite hard to manage and
contractors can do clever things with
their stats so they make sure they get
their performance related pay um and in
the same vein um we can often pay too
much for what they're delivering over
and above um but I think it's a really
good discussion that we'll take back
thank you
yeah and again another question are
there any independent Auditors in the
market who would be able to give you a
very clear because that's how it works
in my industry so you have a set of
pricing commitment you either meet them
or you don't or if or if it looks wooly
then someone's going to there are
companies that pick up on that um and
actually it does work both ways so you
get a situation where you might have
been really busy on behalf of a client
for a year and all of a sudden you get a
you get a performance related bonus that
means actually everyone's very happy at
the end of the year so it it works quite
well hello Council
Davis thanks chair and thanks Sally um
going to repeat the comment I made 24
hours ago
a briefing there's a lot of work gone
into this um I'm interested at how
little anybody that any of us know about
it um I've got some real concerns and
and it's and and thank you for your
input and your work those concerns
relate to this this type of initiative
is only as good and effective as its
monitoring and
enforcement given this
council's
history on monitoring and enforcement
I've got some very real concerns we
can't get enforcement to turn up when
it's necessary we can't get answers from
any form of
enforcement what happens when we've
handed over 165 million potentially of
contract why does it need to be longer
we we currently have a 5-year award
process which gives us an automatic
break and I don't trust the council's
agreements with break Clauses because
we've got lumbered with bretts and all
that toxicity in
Ramsgate yeah
um I have some these are these are very
real concerns um we're putting all of
our eggs in one basket it it's actually
reversal away from localism and plays
into the hands of you know corporate
greed basically who and and and there's
there's an there's a line in 8.1 that
says we have explored other options
these are not recommended one procure
the contract using an open procurement
campaign this is not recommended as not
the approach favored by the market
meaning we may not be able to attract
the contractors we would like to Tender
surely an open and transparent tender
process will attract the either attract
or it won't and if it doesn't attract
the people we think it should then maybe
there's a message in that sorry but I
you know I I I also would like to back
up everything Council managers said I
think we need a latco here I failed to
see the same as I've said previously
with the uh purchase of council housing
how putting a third- party interest
profit ratio into an equation how that
makes it cheaper I don't know
um I'm I'm very confused about why we're
going Outsource Outsource because in
fact in the Grant Thornton external
report which we were discussing only
last week in this chamber one of the key
recommendations is less Outsourcing more
do it ourselves and this seems to be
flying in the face of the
recommendations as well as the the
endemic dangers that I've said so sorry
I'm not trying to ever go at you
personally Sally and I know you've been
instructed no doubt to do this it's been
developed over I presume quite a long
time as well which is why I would like
to make the comment I think it's quite a
shock to all of us that it's at this
stage and I think there
are basic
B there's the we we we should have had
more member involvement and discussion
on this this is a massive decision and
I'm not convinced that all of the logic
in it is actually valid and applicable
but thank
you thank you for your comments I
actually I really appreciate them I
think that's the point of this forum is
for V to challenge what we're doing and
make sure that we're we're doing the
right thing for for our residents and
for the council so I appreciate that
um a couple of points I'd like to come
back on you um mentioned uh that a
contract is only as good and effective
as its monitoring and
enforcement um and and I totally agree
uh when we took the service back in
house the responsive Repairs Service was
was an absolute mess and that was
because there was no contract Management
in place while um it was under East Kent
housing tenure um and the incumbent
contractor could were allowed to just do
what they want since we've taken it back
in house um we have turned that around
I'm I have a lot of confidence in my
Department's ability to manage contracts
and manage them well and that's
evidenced through um the Improvement of
our kpis over the course of the last
three years um which in include kpis for
our turnaround times in voids um our
performance on responsive repairs and
with our customer satisfaction as well
um the I think I'm running away with
myself here so I think the long and the
short of that is um I have a lot of
confidence with my team to be able to
manage the contract that we have we
manage it very well at the moment and I
have no doubt that we will not continue
to manage a new contract in exactly the
same
way the other point that I'd like to
come back on is where you mentioned the
tender
process now you're correct the report
does say that we do not recommend doing
an open tender um this doesn't mean that
the tender that we are proposing the the
strategy that we're going for is is a
two-stage restricted process and what
that means is we open out uh the option
to Tender to anybody that wants to
Tender for it but with a pre-qualifying
questionnaire um so we ask people to to
come in and if they want to they'll do a
pre-qualifying questionnaire and from
that we will choose the five best to
then invite them to carry out of full
tender now the reason we do that um is
to try and attract as much interest in
this contract as possible because a lot
of contractors that are not familiar
with this area or or feel that they
wouldn't have an opportunity to win will
be put off by the fact that um they
could be up against a lot of competition
for a contractor to do a tender like
this would take them a lot of work and a
lot of expense um and if they're put off
they won't do that and that actually
doing an open tender where we just go up
to everybody and invite everybody to do
a full tender process might restrict the
amount of people that we have actually
making an application for this
okay okay so so effectively that becomes
a triage process and yeah I know thank
you for answering that because yeah
um I think the criteria for that triage
process is something that that that's
certainly this committee would want to
have oversight and an input into so that
just just in in in or even awareness of
because transparency is everything and
these major decisions like this um there
there are real concerns about the the
external provision I mean not it's a few
years ago now but premes and I don't I
don't think Ciro were in the mix but
premieres an outfit called DBK were
providing this service to the council
and of course you would expect Capital
adequacy to have been part of our due
diligence process they couldn't even
clear checks for 10 grand and and it
caused uproar and massive damage and yet
this had been notified to the
council what I'm asking for is a
robustness in the
accountability so that we don't keep as
Einstein said you know behaving like
lunatics doing the same thing over and
over again and expecting a different out
come and the evidence Brett's DBK the
evidence has been there for a long time
and if we can overcome those challenges
I'd welcome it because then it makes a
simpler accountability but that
accountability has to be built into the
into the
equation thanks thank chair Council
scobby I think we take Council scobby
then we move on to the thank you chair
um I have a couple of um points to make
I do have to respond to the last speaker
slightly because because um
there's a it's always fun in politics
particularly in scrutiny and Council and
cabinet to have a bit of political
knockabout but um an element of it's a
labor Council so opposition members
throw things but I think we do have to
be factual and two comments that were
made about the Grant Thornton report
clearly recommending that there was no
Outsourcing or the council should do uh
more Outsourcing U sorry less
Outsourcing is you know slightly um
missing the point that report was
talking about progress over time time
and was recommending some gaps based on
a period of 3 or 4 years in governance
it was not suggesting how the council
should be running projects going
forwards and clearly any project would
have to do due diligence and all sorts
of checks so suggesting that a a report
from an external auditor to a governance
and audit committee addressing
governance issues was instructing the
council to do more Outsourcing is
stretching it to the limits and there
also does have to be an element that at
meeting after meeting certain members
keep bringing up is issues that have
happened in The Last 5 Years
continuously to Tar hardworking officers
and a council that is making
improvements maybe too slow for some but
is making improvements we do just need
to push back on that because by
criticizing the council as is and
officers as is most of whom weren't even
in post so we have a whole new senior
leadership team is actually doing some
negative damage because we all need to
be positive and try and take this
Council forward but um that wasn't the
point I was going to make
um one of the things I'm concerned about
in the report is the lack of um uh
coverage on risk management um so under
3.5 it talks about risks and then very
quickly moves on just saying that the
you know the whole risk management
section is is almost uh if we don't do
this the risk is that there won't be
anything and um one of the council's
biggest risk at the moment is cyber
security and it talks under 3.7 of the
covering report that any supplier would
be expected to digitally
integrate um I'm slightly concerned that
that the report doesn't cover the risk
potentially of cyber security and
looking at the industry one of the most
likely ways that Council like TDC would
be impacted um by a cyber security event
would be via a third party that has
access to its systems so I'd just like
to ask a question and this may be
something could be followed up what due
diligence will be done around cyber
security of third parties and then
linked to that under the um attached
report under
5.5.2 it talks about supplier insolvency
as a risk as well it goes on to mention
that this would have serious
council-wide consequen if a supplier
went insolvent but then suggest that a
way of covering that would be a no fault
break clause which of course would be
good protection for the council to stop
it getting any worse but that wouldn't
cover the actual impact of a supplier
becoming insolvent and so I do think
some think some thinking has to go into
what those consequences are because that
has the ability if not properly done to
impact residents to impact Council
Services impact our balance sheet
significantly and it's sort of only
really covered by no fault I I have to
be honest I'm not a expert in housing or
or contracts or procurement or anything
so I certainly take the recommendation
from officers who've done clearly a lot
of work that going with a single
provider may be the best way but the
report keeps talking about that we're
putting all of our eggs in in one basket
and then there doesn't seem to be any
mitigation to that
risk thank you for your questions um I'm
wondering if I can come back up to you
on those questions at a later date
there's feels like there's I don't stuff
I don't know here and I would like to
provide you with a full
response thank
you okay members so let's look at the
recommendation so the recommendation
we're asked to send the cabinet is that
uh the letting of a 10-year contract
with Pro provision to extend for a
further 5year period to enable a true
alliance between contractors and client
this is the provision of responsive
repairs avoids compliance cyclical and
planned works this contract will also
include the element of works for
corporate
properties so that's the recommendation
do we want to make any changes or make
any proposal take for for in relation to
that or are we all happy Council Bri I I
I would like to explore some uh degree
of performance
related fee to be quite honest I think
it needs to be someone needs to be if
it's a 10-year contract the the
contractor needs to be motivated
throughout that the tenure otherwise
it's kind of you know they've got it
sewn up haven't they for 10
years sure is is there only built into
the contract that that um concerns
performance relation or is that is there
anything that we we set out with the
contractor um performance will be um
will be within the contract we will be
set out our expectations on performance
what we don't have is uh the performance
related pay elements here which um I'm
going to take back and look into a
little bit
further okay is that a recommendation I
yeah I was going to ask is there
something I don't know if it's used use
ful so feel free to tell me if it's not
um but thinking about the integration of
this into the housing CAG timetabling
would it be useful for overview and
scrutiny to when we have reports
prepared for the housing CAG for you to
be able to scrutinize what it is that
we're looking at And discussing in
relation
to how the contract is going and how we
can build on minor works and what might
work and what might not in terms of
bringing certain parts forward just an
idea yeah I'm just being made where the
cabinet advisory stuff doesn't come
through scrutiny so is there a recommend
part for the recommendation do you want
to make a change or add something in or
you want to give us the word in that you
want to put in that to take forward to
Cabinet I would I would add something
like explore the uh explore the ability
to lock in some performance related fee
element or something on
they does that
work okay we got that noted uh councilor
maners uh yeah I
am I I feel that this is a bit of a
shotgun wedding um I am disappointed to
to to be here with this um because it
feels like we haven't really got much of
an alternative um and I would hope that
there's every other option is looked at
um to be able to I think TDC had an
opportunity here that's been wasted to
actually prove it could man its own
Affairs and save taxpayers money um and
we've just gone for the I think we've
just gone for the easy option so we are
where we are okay so with regard to the
proposal put forward are you second in
that is that what no you're not
seconding I got I got councelor scob
second in your proposal okay so does
anybody does anybody else want to make
any more amendments do we want to just
go for a vote on
that do we have to take a vote oh yeah
okay so we take a vote on the amendment
that Council for
conf Charles could you just read read
out what amendment we put
forward councilor Bri proposed that um
he would like um the council to explore
performance related monitoring of the
contract uh loing in performance related
fee within the
contract and locking in a performance
related fee fee okay
yeah e either either a malice or a or a
bonus yeah I mean if if they're
fantastic
then
exactly okay so do you all agree with
that we all agree okay so we'll add that
into the
recommendation okay moving on item
number
is there anything else before we move
on um chair could I say something very
briefly if that's okay um I meant to
come back to councelor Davis
earlier um to a certain degree I Echo
your feelings on this um obviously I've
been here since the end of May
effectively
and standard lead time for something of
this scale would be about 3 years I
think we worked out so we can no longer
renew this contract we're at a point
that we know we have to start
procurement now because we do not have
time
to
entirely insource
everything but I disagree that this
is in effect shutting down or only only
choosing one option
um the inclusion of In-House minor works
and the fact that we've got callback and
we've got break
Clauses is an attempt to ensure that
this is an adaptable contract that we
can keep looking at this and as we build
not only our officer numbers and our
operative numbers and our skills in
terms of managing this that we can look
to see if it
is possible to work in other areas and
we can
see how the contract is functioning as a
whole what's presented here today is in
effect a way to open up what otherwise
would be a very very closed book um
and like you I would like to have more
time um but in the time that we have
without risking service and without
risking violating our requirements in
terms of our statutary obligations to
Residents I think ensuring that we are
looking at all options and that we are
keeping that open open in terms of call
back is really important and that's what
I'm trying to do thank
you thanks Helen you've actually just
put into words and Sally in fact with
your response and answered a very real
concern and it's the locking in
y too many times and I'm sorry to Bang
the Drum but there is no no you know
these are the facts and some of us have
been involved with this for a few years
whether in this chamber or outside of
it and the you know the community and
the community purse has been battered by
inadequacies let's call them that in our
arrangements so I have very that's why
I'm very concerned about extending
anything but if that so long as the
break Clauses and the ability to to
change plus nobody knows what the future
holds we're in volatile times and I
think in terms of everything we just
have to be able to if we're riding a
horse we have to be able to sometimes
pull over and swap it so yeah but thank
you thank you again for your answers and
for taking robust questioning in the
spirit it's intended it's not political
it's about getting the truth and
hopefully never going back to where
we've been thank you okay members
so if there's no more comments can we
all please note the report okay moving
on to item number four the tenant and
Lease holder Services quarter 2 report
for 2023 to 24 uh call on Miss o salivan
again thank you um so I am pleased to
introduce our new kpis for q1 and Q2 uh
We've developed a dashboard style way of
reporting and we hope this is more
accessible than our previous reports um
our compliance reports will remain
looking the same for now as um their
requirements are prescribed within our
policy we've also introduced a new
dashboard to show the progress of our
tire blocks retrofits and refurbishment
project because this is a massive
project and I think there's a lot of
interest in it um um most of our
operational pis are running the way we
would like them and I would like to take
the opportunity to run through a couple
of highlights over the last quarter and
also let you know what we're doing in
areas of performance where we would like
to improve firstly um in Q2 we achieved
our voids Target for the first time
since coming back in house and this has
been due to the hard work of our voids
team and strong contract management by
our senior repair
surveyor we're also continuing to reduce
our tenant arear which has now fallen to
under 4% sitting at 3.9 which is a
massive achievement when we took the
service back in house areas were around
7% where we need to do better is with
our Capital spend and capital works we
have struggled to procure contracts over
the last 6 months and finally at the end
of Q2 we're in a position to award a few
contracts and this means over the next
six months we hope to catch up on much
of the capital program that we've fallen
behind on for our compliance statistics
sorry I'm tripping over my teeth now um
we are again operating steadily for most
of our work streams I would like to
highlight the progress made on
electrical safety program which has
increased to
97.67% we can we can prove to them we
have done everything possible to ensure
the safety of this resident um and the
local
community uh we are also unfortunately
having to apply for an injunction to
clear this property to allow Works to be
completed um that's all I wanted to say
on this report but would' be happy to
take any
questions thank you members there
several reports I'm sure you've all read
them no comments at all Council Davis
just one comment to say positively
and and no the in all the indices for
for what you've done since you've and
and I'm going to use your phrase in
house you brought the service the
council brought the services you're
responsible back in house with thriving
compared to where we were can you see
where my argument is about Outsourcing
if we can do it so well there why not
replicate that process you know let's
make light McDonald's and if you're
doing it good do it again and again and
again and suddenly
yeah thank you
though councelor
menz yeah I'm going to Echo what what
John said there that that it's all move
that looks like it's all moving in the
right direction and to get uh the rental
reers down below 4% is is is actually
quite a good good thing you know that's
a good place to be uh one question on
that though um what is do we have a a
properly robust um eviction procedure
for talant that can that won't pay and
refuse to
move yes is the answer the simple
response is yes is that outsourced or no
it's not outsourced we do we do that
ourselves um we have a we have published
a policy um which is for uh income to I
can't think of the right words now sorry
for Recovery of income um and that
includes our uh policy position on
evictions as well um the team have
robust procedures in place um and the
ethos that they take is one of support
so we will do everything within our
power to engage with residents that are
in rental reers and provide them with
the tools to be able to manage um their
finances to pay their rent and sustain
their tency and that's our first Port of
core um where we do apply for eviction
is uh traditionally where our residents
will not engage with us um but we we try
every way to engage we will send letters
we'll make phone calls we'll send texts
we'll go and visit them um before we
move to that part of the process which
we do obviously unfortunately have to
carry out from time to
time councelor White had you indicated
yeah sorry chair I think down to speak
on this one um it's really just a
summing up and a thank you um these
reports are always very very thorough a
huge amount of work goes into collecting
and analyzing data within housing and
the comprehensive nature of this work is
something that I believe officers
involved deserve significant credit for
um for me i' would like to especially
praise the new dashboard style reporting
um I think that makes information far
more accessible and very clear to
understand and I also welcome the
inclusion of in-depth reporting on our
Tower block retrofit and refurbishment
program this is an absolutely massive
piece of work
um it's already included an inclusive
and comprehensive resident consultation
and I think including this as a separate
work stream is exceptionally positive as
I think it's of interest to both
residents and
members I'm heartened that gas
compliance only has one outstanding case
and that it's linked solely to very very
complex access issues as I think this
indicates the level of effort we have
made and are making to ensure that we
are protecting residents and on a
similar note the drop in tenant arear is
extremely positive considering the level
of financial stress that many residents
are currently facing I think this says a
huge amount about the support that our
team are giving to Residents um to help
them access of the support that they may
be entitled to and support them when
times are this
challenging our work in relation to
voids is also very pleasing uh faster
turnaround times mean more families
accommodated more quickly which is
essential to reduce disruption to
families and provide secure
accommodation as quickly as
possible Miss Miss Sullivan's reports
are always very thorough and this is
absolutely no exception I want to
recognize all of the work that goes into
cating and presenting this and I extend
my thanks to you and to all involved
thank
you Council
Patman yeah um I think I ask you this
every time it comes up about we've got
uh two commercial units under lease
which is Newton and Brunswick what about
M mid Hall this is right in my ward and
it does sit there quite empty quite a
lot of the time um is there any plans to
lease this out to a community
organization or use of a TDC building
thank
you um we we've kept mme inh house and
um have chosen not to put this on a
commercial lease I I don't really know
why but we do take bookings for it so um
it's quite full at the weekends at the
moment um I think we've got a couple of
church groups that go in we have in the
past had mother and baby groups that
have used it during the week as well so
there is an opportunity for people to
hire out the hall at at various times I
think at the moment it's being used by
Rise um to for the the overnight
accommodation yeah I I just think that
there could be better use for the hall
it does I know there are bookings and I
go past every Sunday morning and there's
a church group in there and Rise are in
there at the moment but it does sit
there empty and I get a lot of emails
from residents um asking what we're
doing with it um and I think it could be
better used with maybe the school next
door or something like that so I don't
know could you have a look into what we
could do with it I don't know absolutely
thank
you good comment thank
you councelor
faruki thank you very much for this very
thorough and well written report we
really appreciate it um because you
mentioned the resident who um is a
hoarder and you have difficulty with the
gas um certificate and so forth has
there been the safeguarding team
involved to confirm that that Resident
is actually also in a place of safety so
for example if they had a fall that an
ambulance crew would be able to actually
get in and you know do what needed to be
done and so
forth yes um this is a very very complex
case that we have known about for a
number of years um this is the first
time we haven't been able to complete a
gas safety certificate in the property
um but we do have multi- agency
involvement with it and and have done
for a while this resident unfortunately
um does not engage with us which is why
we've had to move to a position of legal
enforcement to be able to ensure that
the property is safe for them to reside
in
now okay members if there no more
comments uh do we have any
recommendations you want to take forward
to cabinet with this
report no okay if not then can we all
note the report please thank you and
thanks Sally pretty tough hour okay
moving on to item number five the Jackie
Bakers Recreation ground I call on Mr
Humber to introduce the
report thank you chair um this report
sets out proposals for cabinets approval
for improvements at Jackie Baker's
Recreation ground the report refers to a
petition that was received by Council in
June about the management of Jackie
Bakers and described the action
taken since then the report also
proposes the adoption of a master plan
which can be found at Annex one of the
report for the future development of the
site the master plan proposals are not
currently funded but the adoption of the
plan will inform the direction and
represent a first step towards securing
the required funding for the long-term
future of Jackie
Bakers the report further proposes that
Authority be delegated to investigate
the options for future development on
the site based on the master plan
including car parking a new Pavilion and
other sporting and recreational
facilities that might enhance the offer
at the site a further report will be
presented to overview and scrutiny panel
and to Cabinet once these options have
been further explored the recommendation
includes the demolition of the existing
Pavilion subject to planning prior
approval being granted next week at the
meeting of planning committee following
demolition it is proposed that temporary
facilities are provided with Team
changing rooms showers officials
changing storage and toilets thank
you okay I call on Miss or councel join
bite please thank you chair um I welcome
the much needed investment in the Jackie
Bakers Recreation ground but I wonder if
officers and Future Park designers will
specifically be considering the needs of
girls and young women in these new plans
women and girls are much less likely to
use Sports Fields than men and boys and
they frequently don't feel comfortable
visiting these spaces as they have not
been designed with their needs in mind
Recent research from Leeds University
and the charity Mak space for girls
identified issues such as a lack of
social seating well-lit paths a lack of
toilets and a focus on facilities
favored by boys as reasons why girls
were less likely to use Parks than
boys the research showed teenagers using
multi-use games areas such as football
fields and basketball courts were 92%
boys and young men facilities such as
tennis courts play spaces and outdoor
gyms were more likely to be used by
girls but still only
34% the draft master plan for Jackie
Bakers imagines a facility used by the
whole Community but in reality these
type of fac facilities do not properly
cater for 50% of the population teenage
girls are less likely to exercise
outside than teenage boys and this isn't
going to change unless we apply gender
mainstreaming in the planning and design
of parks and recreational spaces the
proposed investment in this large
Recreation site seems like the perfect
opportunity for thanet District Council
to lead by example and prove that
teenage girls have as much right to
outdoor fun as teenage boys other
countries and other local councils have
successfully designed parks to be more
inclusive would it be possible to make a
point of ensuring the the facilities at
Jackie Bakers appeal to girls and boys
more equally perhaps we could consult
with local schools and youth
organizations to find out the needs and
requirements of local girls to ensure
these facilities are designed to be as
gender inclusive as possible thank
you thank you councelor um I have to
absolutely agree and I think it's
fundamental to um you know the design
work for those spaces that we are
thinking about uh inclusivity thinking
about designing out risk and making sure
that these are safe open spaces for
everyone in the community to you so you
completely agree and I think that's
that's part of uh part of the process
that we need to go
through okay members Council scobby
thank you chair um I really welcome the
focus on Jackie Bakers and you know the
cross party political support there was
when the petition came came to council
um we all know thanet District Council
does not have enough budget to look
after all of its assets so when we do
actually have a plan come before us to
invest in an asset that has been
underfunded and left to um its current
state this a cause for celebration and
something that we should be positive
about so I really do welcome that and um
I think thanks has to go to the
residents who have campaigned for this
and brought that petition as well as to
officers um and to
personally for me to councilors Auburn
Whitehead and councelor Everett for
their work and support on this because
thanet District Council takes a long
time to turn around on some of these
things and it's great that some of this
was already in the pipeline but um a lot
of support's been given and to uh Tony
in particular I think uh it was probably
your first week in work where you were
getting lots of emails and calls to try
and get temporary toilets down there and
temporary facilities just to appreciate
your patience with us um I've got um two
points to make there um the first one is
um around the plans themselves I think
there's um there's diagrams and maps on
page 17 under section two of the report
which I think are misrepresenting don't
even tally with each other and I think
are causing confusion to Residents um
you will look at if you look at the two
of them um I know there is a a a uh a
Proviso within that on page 17 saying
that these are just examples and will
change but the fact they exist means
they get shared it becomes
something that's used on the media as a
key point I think if cabinet adopts
those I I think it would um just
continue that confusion so my my view
and a recommendation I will make later
on after the debate would be that we do
not include those because of the
confusion cause I also think um the
report is from several months ago and
has a whole section about the housing uh
which again I'm not sure even though it
may have been part of the original
report given to the council whether that
should be adop opted because um it
almost suggests that part of the uh
master plan is riant on the housing
which it isn't it also suggests that
there's a decision to be made by cabinet
about the housing which there isn't it
was included in the local plan a
decision's already been made about that
and there will be coming forward as
understand it in the future so I do not
think that um inclusion of that
discussion of housing is relevant
because let's be really really clear of
it with regards to Jackie Baker there is
no politician I'm aware of in thanet
that is suggesting anything other than
keeping that space for the people of
Ramsgate and I think including in a
report about the potential um
development of this for opportunities
for the community and sporting clubs and
dog walk Walkers a section around
housing is especially if it goes out
under recommendations CN D for public um
engagement I just think that's sending
the wrong message so I I would I I think
a recommendation I will make in a bit
chair is that actually the entire
section two of that report is probably
probably Superfluous and doesn't need to
be there the the real details in section
one because in the second part of the
report it is only the on page 17 2.1
discussion of the recommendations which
is effectively the two diagrams maps and
the rest of it is about housing I think
that whole section I think cabinet
shouldn't adopt and just look at the
first section thank you
chair thank you councelor um I think
yeah on on the first point as you've
already pointed out the plans are
illustrative they're sort of options
they're not intended to be um you know
we're going to do one of those one or
the other of those by its nature the
master plan's very high level and there
will be a great deal of work that goes
into detail design with consultation um
but I I I do take your point um but but
that's you know that's the purpose of
those being in there um on the on the
housing um as as I'm sure everyone's
aware um the uh land was transferred
from the general fund to the HRA um and
and that land's referred to in this um
that that site you know there'll be you
certainly there's no um intention that
approving this master plan approves any
of the the housing there that's subject
to planning and subject to I think the
report refers to it coming back to
Cabinet as well the housing so yeah it's
not intended that that this provides
some sort of um authorization some sort
of permission for for for for that but
yeah again take take your point
Council
Austin thank you chair um and thanks for
this report um I'd like to Echo a couple
of things that Council scobby said first
of all that it's really encouraging to
be in a position to be able to respond
to a resident's petition in the prompt
and positive way that we have and
obviously this has been in train for a
while but the timing has worked out
perfectly and if we can present
ourselves as the kind of council that
response to Residents in that kind of
way I think this is a really you know
it's it's a bit of a line in the sound
really and and and very encouraging and
thank you very much um and I'd also like
to Echo what um what council brgh said
about provision for girls and it's been
a concern certainly with with with other
uh Recreation areas so um something that
definitely needs to be borne in mind um
on
the uh on the housing again as Council
scobby said I think it is a distraction
and there has been a great deal of
discussion on social media around which
bits of the land were covenanted to the
people of Ramsgate etc etc I actually
wrote to Mr verel to ask if he had a
copy of a diagram that showed us where
the covenanted land was so that we could
put that all those rumors to rest and he
says he doesn't and sent me the the
which bit was allocated in the local
plan if we can actually
find that document which must be
somewhere in the archives and get it out
there on social media it would be
tremendously helpful to stop the sort of
muttering that's going on about their
building housing on our land Etc which
is is not helpful and is running
contrary to that responsiveness about
the petition thing going on and finally
as um a ward counselor in
uh whose Ward includes a a recreation
area which has what is laughingly
referred to as a skate park where the
tumble weed blows I'd really like to see
us try to improve the facilities we we
have already before we start on trying
to build not not that I don't want to
see great facilities uh at Jackie Baker
but we
have something that refers to itself as
a skate park that we know perfectly well
isn't at the moment that we're trying to
raise funds for and we'd really like to
see things moving on that perhaps in
parallel with some bids going in for new
facilities here thank
you thank you counselor I think on your
first point it sounds like yeah that
there needs to be a a document search
there I can't comment here but I'm sure
we can have a look and and bring it and
bring it back and um yes skat Park and I
know we've had conversations about the
skat Park and yes agree agree I think
yeah okay
councilor
Menace thank you Phil um this is this is
all good stuff um I mean it's sort of
what we all signed up for I think the
the idea that we could start to see
world class facilities for local kids
and people that want to get out there
and and get involved in sport um it's
impossible not to think what a what a
great initiative so I'm really happy
that that this is on the agenda here um
I'd remind
um uh the council or the board that
there's also um a large group of people
jealously peering over the garden fence
in cliftonville East uh who signed a
very similar petition for a very similar
project in northdown park um and I hope
that will come before this Committee in
the very near future as well um I am
mindful though that you you can only
spend a pound once and are we are we
spreading ourselves be robbing Peter to
pay Paul slightly um is this this is
this looks like a brilliant goldplated
scheme I I understand that Mike saying
that it's not yet funded um but it will
take an awful lot of funding to get
there obviously um and can we actually
afford it and is there are there savings
that can be made um in actually
achieving a massive Improvement at
Jackie bakers with whil still leaving
budget for the other projects and I I
note what councelor has said with skate
parks I mean we've all got those
facilities within our constituencies our
wards where we would like to see this
this kind of investment um with that in
mind um I was curious what the budget
was for the temporary uh sport structure
what the longevity was for that
structure um versus the cost of removing
the asbestos from the existing roof and
perhaps replacing the uh existing roof
if if it needed to be replaced and a
quick toou up in side how those numbers
kind of balanced out and given given the
time scale we're looking at um that
would be one thing I'd look at um but
also to to uh keep keep our eyes on the
ball so that we're able to deliver on
northdown Park and the Pavilion there as
well thank
you yeah so thank you councelor manners
um so one of the key things with Jackie
Bakers the the petition was from the the
um Sunday football league uh secretary
um uh the Kent fa through their football
facilities fund have identified Jackie
Bakers as a potential uh area for
funding um so it gives it a unique
situation where if we invest um we can
then get um the same amount of funding
potentially from the fa we need the um
master plan document in order to be able
to start that process of discussion with
Kent FAA so it's really quite crucial
that we have some form of plan in place
that they can then start to see that
they can look at for their own funding
scenarios um we also need to be in a
position where we can move quickly
because notoriously uh sport England
funding uh which it would be sport
England funding through the fa um and
the football uh football Foundation
funding is always with really tight time
scales for actual being in the ground
and delivered um so we need to have all
of those those things in place
I think it's it's really evident that um
there are projects that could go on in
in a number of parks and play areas um
throughout the district and we are
working on those as well and and as as
we've already uh discussed with Council
Austin so um I'll take away the
northdown park scenario um and work on
that as well um but there is one of me
so I'm going as quick as I can
um your second point about the
Pavilion um so you're right to identify
there is a quite substantial amount of
asbestos in that Pavilion which is the
reason why the demolition costs are as
high as they are the other scenarios
within the Pavilion are that the m& is
actually outdated and not efficient and
and not working well um so it's it's
going to be a situation where we'd have
to replace the roof uh as you quite
rightly identified but we'd also have to
strip out all m& from the site to make
it
uh more efficient to be in line with our
you know uh climate pledge so we believe
that with all of the things that we've
seen in terms of The Pavilions um the
things that need to be addressed with
the Pavilion um on that basis it would
make more sense to um de demolish The
Pavilion and replace with a temporary
changing facility the intention is that
the temporary changing facility will be
a container type facility but it's as a
porter cabin scenario um we hope that
that will give it longevity rather than
it being a porter cabin that's the
normal classroom type facility that
could be damaged quite
easily uh thank you Tony um just one
quick thing on that has a an asbest
survey taken place yet and also um have
we had we have we had a survey on the
building to know well on on but I mean
as an aspor survey and the demolition
costs seem extraordinarily High um by a
factor of about 400% actually um and I
just wondered had had we had a number of
competitive quotes for the
demolition so where we are at the moment
is that we have had a report on the
Pavilion in terms of what what is wrong
with it um and and we are now in the
process of getting approval to take
forward a Qs report to get the final
demolition costs on the Asbestos and the
entire Pavilion um that Qs report has
not been done yet um the work that's
been done so far is from our internal
surveyors within the council the
internal surveyors have talked about
that figure um being worst case scenario
they didn't want to kind of go too low
on the figure I am in agreement with you
that potentially there could be a lower
figure to the Pavilion
demolition um and I'm quite Keen that
the Qs report happens once we get
approval to do the demolition so that we
can then start to look at at the cost
once the Qs report has been done we will
then go out to Tender on an open tender
basis to make sure that we get best
value for money in terms of the
demolition of the of the
site councilor scobby thank you chair
for letting me speak a second time
especially as I'm gate crashing your
committee I just wanted to make um
couple of points um that at the moment
as I understand there isn't actually
funding committed to this Beyond drawing
up down from the risk management Reserve
to cover the changing rooms there is
obviously potential borrowing funds from
that housing land being moved um and uh
section 106 contributions but I think as
um as officers said this is not a case
of suddenly finding money to fund this
or we're at a very early stage of it um
and there does need to be I completely
hear colleagues talking about um parks
and Open Spaces in their Wards I mean
we've got another one in Northwood that
needs some um care and attention I think
Jackie Bakers do have does have to be
looked at differently it actually has
its own uh separate policy within the
local plan G7 which specifically states
that Jackie bakers will be protected as
a place for sports and recreation so
this is not a space like any other
within thanet it's been specifically set
out by counselors for investment for
things like this so there is actually a
special case for investment there and
um I get in trouble with with saying
these words um because I think residents
take it the wrong way but the council is
always looking for new revenue streams
and there is the opportunity that if
there are sports facilities put up there
of the magnitude we're looking at that
has a potential to be a very useful
Revenue stream for the council which can
be reinvested into Grassroots Sports and
potentially into improving services in
other ways which does not exist in other
Open Spaces in thanet or has not been
protected in the same way so I
appreciate you letting me speak speak a
second time chair thank you councilor
B I'd just like to Echo what what
councilor Mana said about this is
actually really exciting when reports
coming our way uh for something so
positive is good I'd also uh
unsurprisingly Echo what councilor brgh
said and I really do think we need to
have a vision around um around provide
carrying out due diligence around
delivering solutions that girls and
young women do want and will use I think
you know mult that that point about
multisport it it still doesn't really
cut the mustard so um looking elsewhere
at really good examples uh looking far a
field I know there are really good
examples strangely in in Romania that
are that are really that really work
well uh and I'd just like to come on um
back to one one point obviously this
isn't my ward um and there are a lot of
things that I would love to see done in
my ward but Northwood is is is one of
the I believe one of the more deprived
Wards in the District um and I think we
have to weigh up cost and benefit and
the benefits to the mental health uh and
the positive outcomes that a a project
like this delivers across what is a
large W with a large school um they they
kind of they they impact on a lot of
different areas of of what goes on in
thanet so you're looking at better
mental health outcomes better education
outcomes Better Health outcomes um so I
think it's something sometimes we we
just really need to to to deliver on a
project in a big way and I I I really
support this um this this
project that wasn't a question a
question and thank you and and comments
noted and I agree thank you
yeah councelor Davis thank you chair um
again really welcome this Jackie Bakers
is it is as been said it's a hub it's a
Sports Hub it's a health Hub it's a
facility and I think it transcends we
hear a lot about Wards we're all equally
responsible though we're elected by Ward
and this facility affects every Ward
probably in Ramsgate and a lot of
broadstairs as well because it has a
huge draw quite correctly I think Mike's
identified there's revenue of available
because it's a few years ago now but in
the 80s there was a regular
international hockey tournament there
where the place was absolutely choler
block and it brought in loads of money
for TDC so we're not Reinventing the
wheel all we're actually doing is sort
of waking up from years of having ah
head somewhere where we obviously
weren't looking in the right direction
um I'd also just like
to while I'm being non-political back up
my colleague counselor scy
um there was a lot of confusion and it
was to do with a very poorly headlined
press piece when there was a plan the
planning application first went in for
these houses that set off the social
media Ferrari of oh they're building on
it and so on so I think there is a bit
of PR recovery to be done there and
probably not having housing in the
master plan for sport would be a a good
start to
that but no fabulous news and for all
and particular my grandson is an aage
user of Jackie Bakers I understand so
therefore I'll declare that interest
however one major point but it's a minor
Point Jackie Bakers despite signage this
document and everything else is spelled
j a c KY and it's the name of a former
operator of the land before Dame Janet
stank and Wells gifted it to the people
of this community so I think we've got a
bit of editing to do because it's got an
e shove in it all over the show but it I
can assure you it is and if you look at
the land registry and the actual
official records it's Jackie Bakers j a
c KY I hope we can get on to that and
get the necessary edits done thank
you uh Council Austin I just wanted to
pick up on the the comments about girls
and young women we we have a youth
council could we contact councelor Keane
who I think is the Cabinet member who
links with the youth Council and maybe
see if we can get some advice through
that route about the kinds of things
that might appeal to girls and young
women as part of this
facility um yes is the answer councelor
Austin yes uh absolutely okay I I think
the youth Council might be a topic for
scrutiny at a at a later date yeah okay
okay members any further comments you'd
like to make before a look at the
recommendations
okay I'll go through because there's a
number of recommendations I'll go
through them one at a time
uh recommendations cabinet are that
cabinet approves the demolition of the
existing Pavilion on the basis of health
and safety subject to the local planning
Authority giving prior approval do we
all agree with that
one sorry are you two okay
though okay I'll read that out again uh
the recommendations to Cabinet are that
cabinet approves the demol demolition of
the existing Pavilion on the basis of
health and safety
subject to the local planning Authority
giving prior approval do we all agree
with that just
just that cabinet approves the purchase
of a temporary portter cabin style
changing facility once the demolition
has occurred do we all agree with
that okay okay uh uh next one is that
cabinet approves a public engagement
exercise to inform the master planning
for Jackie Bakers based on the draft
master plan attached to Annex
one councilor scobby can I propose a um
an amendment to that um and the the
sentence ends based on section one of
the draft master plan attached at Annex
one so I think if you go out to public
consultation with
maps that do not properly cover what's
happening plus housing which is not
relevant to the master plan in my
opinion I think that's not that's not a
uh a good
plan so you want something removed from
I'm adding the words between based on
the the draft master plan but based on
the words so instead of attached to
Annex one what just fig out you what you
want to say yeah let me just work this
out fully sorry so uh between the words
on and the based on section one of the
draft master
plan okay got that and and because this
we're not decision makers here're
obviously recommending if there are
sections from section two which I don't
think there is that officers think are
relevant to potential funding bids from
other people but having looked at it I
don't think there is but cabinet have
the ability to put those back in if
needed but I I think the whole of
section two isn't
relevant
okay the second proposal Council Austin
and all agree with that okay good moving
on to the next one uh the cabinet
delegates Authority the chief executive
officer to investigate the options for
future development on the site based on
the master plan to include a new car
park new Pavilion to include changing
facilities and other sporting stroke
recreational facilities that might
enhance the offer at the site a report
on that will be represented to the
overview and scrutiny panel and
compliance cycle and I got the wrong
[Applause]
s so many
pages uh and the cabinet once these
options have been further explored do we
agree to that one yes okay and also last
one the cabinet recommends the council a
oneoff 2324 supplementary general fund
Revenue budget of 370,000 be approved
for the demolition of the existing
Pavilion and the provision of a
temporary P cabin facility to be funded
from the risk Reserve do we all agree to
that we all agree is there any other
recommendation You' like to put forward
councelor bri can we just make a
recommendation about young women and
girls so I think um recommendation to
ensure exploration of installation of
facilities that will encourage the safe
enjoyment of Jackie Bakers by girls and
young women you got down yeah is that
right yeah if you give that to to
Charles cuz you said it so fast I don't
think okay I I'll I'll say it slowly
yeah St Lear uh the recommendation to
ensure exploration of installation lots
of Asians yeah explore that we will in
yeah will be installed okay to ensure uh
to explore that facilities will be
installed that will encourage the safe
enjoyment of Jackie Bakers by girls and
young
women is that okay do I have a second on
that and we all agree to that are we all
agreeing okay councelor manager you
wanted to put sign forward uh yeah just
on the temporary the temporary Pavilion
uh that it be properly insured given the
vulnerability that we know that we've
had with the temporary public toilets
that have been burnt out by some you
know people in the night um that Jackie
Bakers is could be a little bit
vulnerable there that the this the
sighting of them be looked at very
carefully given that uh temporary
structures are usually more vulnerable
and also look at Insurance yeah sure I
would have thought insurance goes
without go saying but I think Mr Momo
already said that it's was going to be
some sort of strength strength and uh
facilities you want to come back yeah
chair so the intention is to use the
existing utilities and slab uh to site
the temporary facility and the existing
insurance will cover that that that site
so yeah it will be
insured counc as as local counselors and
with the residents who did the petition
we have engaged with the local police as
well and there are residents who are um
following police advice to flag up any
incident because there have been a lot
of incidents of antisocial behavior and
um we don't want what happened at the
warre to be repeated at um Jackie Bakers
where the council invest money and then
things happen and then you just can't
keep doing that so absolutely we're
going to be working with residents to
try and make sure it's
safe councelor Davis ironically although
there's the pr issue with the housing
having that housing along that area and
adjacent to it I think will make all the
difference in in terms of um you know
occupation or security through
occupation it'll make it because at the
moment the gates are there and it's just
an open field having activity and and
traffic there will foot
traffic okay thank you uh so if there's
no more recommendations uh do we all
note the report okay moving on item
number six the public toilets
refurbishment and renewal project I call
on Mr Humber again to introduce the
report thank you chair so this report
proposes a schedule of investment in
public toilets around the district
budgets totaling 1.25 million with a
mixture of Revenue and capital funding
have been
identified a further sum of £250,000 is
anticipated although not yet approved
approved via an external uh Grant from
Southern
water the report proposes maintenance
works at seven sites this will focus on
addressing existing defects and is not a
full refurbishment of the toilets but it
will return them to a much higher
standard of repair examples of the work
content can be found at Annex one along
with the estimated cost the total spend
on Revenue repair works is estimated at
£ 279,000
and subject to approval at cabinet it is
proposed to undertake these works in the
new year so that they are complete
before the start of the 2024 season the
report also proposes Capital works at
three sites those being Margate Clock
Tower Stone Bay and botony Bay these
Capital Works will provide significantly
improved and accessible facilities at
all three
sites there are currently 27 public
toilets in thanet and this report
proposes work at 10 of those 27
locations this investment is proposed to
be the start of an anticipated wider and
longer term program of public toilet
improvements subject to further funding
being identified the report also
proposes that a further report be taken
to Cabinet before the end of October
2024 to provide an update on toilet
refer fish M and Improvement works the
report will update on the capital Works
program and will propose next steps to
address refurbishment or improvements at
public toilets not included in this
initial phase thank
you thank you Mr I call on a member of
public I've I can't see former member of
the council M Ruth
Bailey
thank you and good evening I hope my
voice LS it's councel whitee I'm
suffering a
bit um as some will know this is a
subject that I've raised quite often in
the past so I wanted to come along this
evening to welcome this long awaited
toilet
strategy this issue is of is is of great
importance to Residents and visitors
alike and I speak from experience being
in the front line listening to
complaints we're manning the visitor
information kiosk in
broadstairs we know that toilet
provision is not a statutory duty but
clean hygienic toilets particularly in
the seaside destination are
essential having this strategy in the
public Arena at last is a real positive
step forward so well done to all
concerned the report is clear and honest
in its limitations the detailed
rationale costings schedule of works is
welcome as is the re reassessment of um
disability and baby changing
provision it was pleasing to note that
despite fears to the contrary this
refurbishment program does not seem to
entail the closure or selling off of any
of the other toilet facilities not yet
anyway I see from the report that the
first TR of toilets will be ready for
next summer which is great however the
time span of the total program given is
10 years at 3.4 of this report which
does seem rather a rather period I do
hope the funding can be found to speed
this up as I'm not sure some of the
remaining toilets can wait that
long it would be good to know what the
realistic timetable is for the proposed
new builds at Margate botony and stone
Bay as they are all in dire condition as
we
know once the toilets are spruced up and
more acceptable to our residents and
visitors has any thought been given to
introducing a charging system to put
money back into their future
maintenance so similarly has any
consideration been given to having
commercial advertising on the outside of
the toilets where appropriate or even
inside in order to attract
revenue and finally can we dare hope
that once refurbished the toilets will
be open and operational at reasonable
hours especially during the long summer
evenings when people are still out and
about instead of being closed fairly
early in in the or in the late afternoon
early evening I look forward to seeing
the completed works thanks for your time
uh thank you R
uh
M so just um to confirm in 3.4 the um 10
years was actually the Jeff Oliver
report saying that um they estimated it
would take 10 years worth of work to to
um do all the works within the report um
we think that that's not where we are
and we think we can do better than that
subject to
funding
okay just to pick up the um other points
um I think
absolutely um charging and and and sort
of commercial opportunities such as
advertising um need to be considered um
there's quite a lot involved if we were
to move to a model where we charge and
that's not proposed in this report it's
not proposed here um but it's something
to consider in the in the future um but
it's a it's a different model from how
we operate now and requires a different
level of uh attendance particularly CLE
cleaning and attendance at the at at the
facilities but it's it's I agree it's
something for consideration um and in
terms of opening hours um I think um you
we we've talked around this um uh before
and the um the need to do the very best
we can with the resources that we've got
available um and the budgets that we've
got available to to uh open clean and
lock up again toilets um which across 27
sites takes quite some time um the
number of Crews we have available means
that there are some limitations with the
opening hours and we mustn't stay open
too late because of antisocial behavior
that occurs around toilets and damage
that can occur around toilets but take
the point and and it's always our um uh
you objective to to keep toilets open as
long as possible and they the opening
hours are based on priority and footfall
um as much as
possible thank you councelor town in you
did indicate I know you came in
late now thank you for the report
Mike um
firstly these uh seven toilets that
you're talking about uh which you're
going to initially
repair um to bring into use by the
public and
visitors um if you look where they're
located they're not really actually
attacking the areas where we get a
massive amount of u visitors such as
botney Bay such as Central mgate now
these are two very major areas of
visitors and as far as the clock tower
toilets Go I mean they are totally
unusable because they fly
uh very easily uh I mean I I've had
people complain about them uh and at
Botany we don't have a toilet it's it's
it's it's it's a piece of concrete
unusable um you we and then you talk
about um Southern water um sort of
assisting with funding with regards to
portals now we're also talking about
southern water putting up a quarter of a
million pounds to repair toilets and
then we're talking about actually
Southern wat actually funding uh more
portal so is that an addition to the
quarter of a million crit or is that
quarter of million going to fund those
portal L it's going to cost and and the
other thing is this two portal L at bony
Bay are just not worth the trouble
because of the volume of people that go
down there um you need at least
four toilets or more so we're going to
you so what sort of money are we looking
at we're looking at a lot of money I
mean as T has said 10 years are just
unacceptable for repairing these the the
27 toilets but when we look at the
volume the this the amount of money we
are going to require to to actually
repair these toilets over a period of
Time how are we going to repair pay it
where is it coming from thank
you yeah thank you councelor towning um
so as you've highlighted there are seven
toilets which will receive Revenue
repair works so um bringing them back to
an acceptable standard but not
undertaking Improvement works as such um
you mentioned botony Bay and um Margate
and those will be along with stone Bay
will be the focus of capital work so at
Margate it's investment of £400,000
in improved and accessible toilets so a
much higher standard and um at botony
Bay uh subject to that funding from
Southern from Southern water it will be
Improvement to the existing facilities
plus providing additional accessible
facilities which won't be portaloo type
toilets it will be um a more permanent
Arrangement um so so um you sort of
event type toilets or secure toilets um
on the other side of the bay this is
that all subject to planning and and you
know further approval so those sites
that you
mentioned the proposal is to invest in
those um you know more heavily with with
a greater amount of funding so that
they're improved and accessible uh
facilities
um I think yeah sorry I think that's
probably covered the the points in terms
of
incre you this this report is quite
clear that the F you know this is the
start of a start of a journey a start of
a strategy the funding Beyond this this
work for these 10 toilets is not
identified yet but that's that's work
that needs to be done and the commitment
in the report is to come back in October
next year to um talk about the next
phase of that uh along with a a funding
strategy can we just look at the small
amount of money of
400,000 okay obviously that's a capital
expenditure um
so however long we borrow it over uh
we're going to have to repay the
interest on that where are we going to
find the money to repay that interest
cuz the toilets are free and as you
quite rightly point out getting
advertising and things like that is not
ideal opportunity
property to go about and charging for
toilets uh there used to be a slogan
about things like that years ago but I
you know where is the money going to
come not just to pay the 400 but to pay
a couple of million was probably further
down the road where is the money going
to come from to repay that in that that
Capital sum and
interest so in answer to your question
for the money identified in this report
the the 400 identified in this report um
that is actually the the borrowing will
be repaid using an existing budget which
is still available um the toilets used
to attract business rates they don't
anymore and that budget is still
available and that budget will pay for
the borrowing uh so in this instance
there is a provision and it's it's set
out in the report as to how we cover the
borrowing cost um future funding needs
to be uh yeah as I said we will'll need
to be um to a future
report councelor
cup sorry chair thank you um surprise
surprise I want to talk on toilet wow
don't laugh uh as Ruth knows it's was my
favorite subject to council as I was
often questioned on it um I I would just
like to
to sound Elvis what's wrong with sound
like Elvis
uh yeah I won't do my impression of
Elvis so I just wanted to firstly
congratulate this coming forward I I
know how much work has gone into this uh
bearing in mind that the the foundations
of this uh were set out uh under the
previous
administration and the amount of times
that we had to look into things and then
stop looking into certain areas because
of uh fee back we received coming up
with ideas and being critical of those
ideas and the one thing I found that
with the toilets you are never ever
going to win no matter what you put on
the
paper I um firstly I know it's not on on
the report but I would just like to
comment about the charging of the
toilets I I don't think it's a good idea
I think it's um there there is concern
around if you look at a study undertaken
by Southeastern trains who used to
charge for their toilets uh when they
sto charging for them they saw a drastic
incre decrease in the amount of people
that used to um do their business
elsewhere other than the toilets um and
also when people are walking around in
their their trunks and whatever else
they don't carry cash or card with them
and it just it just gives a reason for
people to go and and do things elsewhere
I am slightly concerned regarding the
the funding from Southern water I think
it is a a nice idea absolutely um
but I'm concerned that it's not cemented
when this report is already coming to
overview and scrutiny and once again
when it goes to Cabinet um and I think
that that really really needs to be
tightened up very much
so a question that
I uh wanted around
this
oh what's so I just have all of them
on uh I'll sit further
away turn it away
feedback electric
personality uh oh God so sorry the
question uh I was trying to get to is um
Mike as you know there was there was
plans around us putting Provisions in
place with works with your leisure now
we were looking at a process to to
ensure that the toilets would stay open
by giving the management of those
toilets to your leisure we were looking
at your leisure taking on some of those
toilets um so that they would be able to
also open up more of their Provisions
providing beat charts and what I want to
understand is is are those conversations
just completely stopped um because I
feel like as as much as it's fantastic
news the investment right now what is
the future plan here
and um are those conversations
completely stopped with with your
leisure for that that future proofing
and trying to help the concerns that
residents came to us about opening them
and cleaning them and things like that
thank you
chair thank you councelor cup um so I
think before those conversation I mean
those conversations aren't going on at
the moment to to be to be clear before
any conversation such as that can can
happen um we need to have toilets that
are at an acceptable standard um that
could potentially be transferred so um
to to to be clear no those conversations
aren't going on at the moment and that
they couldn't do until we have I think
we've we've improved the standard of of
the
toilets councelor
maners thank you chair um yeah I share
George um George's pleasure at seeing uh
finally some uh progress on toilets
particularly although um the the boty
bay toilet strictly speaking isn't in
Clifton Ville East um it it probably in
the summer it's about half of our half
of our problems are people looking for
toilets around that part of the world
um one issue with uh Southern water uh I
attended a a community engagement
meeting in Ramsgate where ash Ashby uh
was on the panel together with the CEO
of uh Southern water and it was
announced at that meeting that funding
had been secured for this same public
toilet at botony that we're now talking
about so I'm a little bit concerned this
this seems to be an extraordinarily long
courtship without any consummation so
far um and um I speak on a fairly
regular basis with the commun um the uh
uh engagement um team at Southern water
because of our the other hat I wear with
the friends of botony bay and I know
that southern B they're not the most
perfect company in the world is is uh as
will be pointed out by many I suppose
but they are very keen to make amends
for the historic damage that they've
caused um and I suspect are very keen
also to put this one to bed and and be
seen to be doing so so I'm would would
ask are we having a productive
engagement um with Southern water um and
where are we up to in that
relationship um I also think that uh
we're talking about huge amounts of
money being spent here um on assets
which they're not really assets are they
they're overhead if you think about it
um you know we're going to spend
hundreds of thousands if not over a
million or what are we looking at 650 if
we include Stone Bay and botony um on
something that's just going to cost us
more and more money and I think there is
scope to look at partner parnerships
with um the private sector to deliver on
public toilets if you're in the High
Street and you get caught short you pop
into Costas to use the loo you don't
walk down to the harbor front in
Ramsgate to use the public toilet there
you're going to weather spoons probably
um and um at botony Bay um the landlord
I spoke to there gets through 12
industrial size L rolls every single day
whenever it goes above 25° at the
weekend um the we do have a public
toilet at botony Bay it's it's the
botony Bay Hotel um now if there is
£250,000 of seed funding on the table is
it at botony is it not possible to look
at a partnership with a private operator
who who might be able to provide uh
toilet provision uh in in return for a
softening of the terms of a long lease
whereby they might invest some of their
own money as well at Stone Bay there is
a very successful ful uh young
entrepreneur who's got some sort of
kiosk type concession there and I
understand that he has already
approached TDC to uh with regard to
getting permission to put a more
permanent structure on that site why not
partner with people like that to provide
the public toilet provision in in return
for as I say concessions on on the uh
the the rent on his lease give them a
security of tenure give them a long a
long enough lease and ask them to invest
some of this money and I suspect that if
there's over £400,000 on the table to be
invested that that could create
something that would not only provide a
destination venue in terms of food and
beverage offering but also probably some
of the smartest public toilets that we
would have in broadstairs um so I just
wonder if those conversations are taking
place um and um yeah as I said the more
the public the the it is important for
our visitor economy that we've got these
public toilets sorted um and if the
private sector can do it efficiently
let's look to them thank
you um so just to um give you current
position with Southern water we we have
had confirmation emails from them in
terms of they wish wish to fund uh
Botley Bay um toilets where they are at
the moment is they're just doing a Qs
report on how much they need for that
and then they will start to look at uh
finally announcing what commitment they
will make towards uh the funds that are
there so as far as we're aware at the
moment they are giving us emails that
commit to looking at botney Bay but they
don't know how much money and they've
sort of talked about it might be as much
as 250 it might be more it might be less
but that was the number that they wanted
to put into the public domain um but as
it stands at the moment where they are
is it's Qs reports that need to happen
and and that's what we're waiting
for yeah um I mean I think you know it's
interesting points raised I um am aware
of uh in other areas where um that model
is is tried um I know um from
um other authorities where they've had
uh issues with trying to uh particularly
in existing businesses trying to get
existing businesses to allow toilets to
be to be um used publicly and they um
other authorities have done surveys
around that to gauge interest and had
sort of not a great response to that but
on the basis of a a commercial uh
agreement where a site is uh put forward
obviously that would be subject to
competition it would need to be at the
sort of value that you're talking that
that we're talking about um it's a yeah
it's not a model that we're looking at
here um we're looking at providing um
public toilets where we maintain the
control of those at least in the short
term to be able to open them and close
them when we want that to happen and uh
clean them to the standards that we want
and all those things um I think it's
something that that um that that isn't
considered here but happy to you know
you know consider that and and think
about those
options thanks I I do think though if
TDC is the actual Freeholder of the
property um and you've got the a
properly drawn up lease that you do have
the whip hand over dictating uh the
terms the opening times the standards
and so on uh for which the public
toilets could be maintained um the the
difference would be that you're
delegating that responsibility to the uh
the lcy or the the lese um their
motivation to do so is obviously that
they wouldn't want their customers using
substandard toilets the same as Costa
and KFC don't um but also the their
their entire business model would depend
upon them doing so because you would
have the ultimate sanction over the
lease that that was the the point really
with that and obviously the idea that
there are private um entrepreneurs out
there one one of whom I've spoken to
this week in stone Bay um who willing to
introduce their own capital and if we
can spend other it's it's much bit
better if we can spend other people's
money um maybe that came out the wrong
way but you know what I
mean okay uh take Council counc Davis
and councelor Austin and then I think we
need to move on because there a lot of
recommendations to go
through thank you um I hugely welcome
this I I didn't know until May just how
important uh public toilets were so um a
lot of conversations particular
particularly in the summer and and the
fact that you're looking at um the
improvements to Broad says is is is
really important I think these will pay
for itself so yes they are an overhead
but you know BR says fol week alone
generates Mill literally millions of of
of pounds for the local economy so I
think this anything that gets people
coming and coming back again is is a
good thing um you already answered my my
first question which was are we asking
for enough given that southern water is
so Keen um but obviously You' you've
gone away and you're having those
conversations which is great the other
the the point I would I would raise is I
completely agree with councelor cup on
charging um and I I like the idea of of
of add Revenue but it would be
negligible frankly um one thing that I
do want to know um is with regard to the
next stages of the toilet so for example
Victoria Gardens in broadstairs um have
full surveys been undertaken of the the
infrastructure behind them so not just
the the the toilet blocks themselves but
also the plumbing underneath because
some of those blocks are probably at
least 100 years old now um so have has
that work done uh been done and is it
available to to look
[Music]
at uh yeah thank you counselor so uh the
uh what's refer to in here is the the
Jeff Oliver and associates survey is
essentially a dilapidation survey so it
looks at it's it's largely visual so it
looks at the things that can be seen so
where manual covers can be lifted they
be lifted and look but it won't include
things like
a you know CCTV survey of of the drain
pipe of the of the F sewer pipes
underneath um so that's the level of
survey undertaken uh to date so no for
for for more detailed information and
the sort of information you'd need for
Capital Improvement works or for you
know for that sort of thing then yes
that that additional survey were be
required councilor
Davis thanks chair thanks Mike
um just wanted to clarify one thing this
Southern water money the 250k it says
here Southern water have discussed the
possibility of committing now our
understanding from a couple of years ago
was that this was set in stone and that
was I was at the same meeting in
Ramsgate that was uh discussed at so is
this the same money that's now become a
possibility or are we trying to give
credit twice for it um where is it if
not where's the money that they promised
two years ago because that was an
unequivocal promise from that stage I
think Council of Whitehead was at the
same meeting weren't
you I Royal Harbor at the Royal Harbor
you were definitely there um as were
quite a number of now um that was
committed so why are we now just talking
about possibilities that's that's that's
question one um however I'd also like to
bring to the attention there's a
particular set of toilets and need that
isn't being addressed and never appears
on these lists and that's on the uh West
West Western
Undercliff because Southern water
managed to flood the cafe and toilets
down there to the point where it was
deemed to be not viable to
reinstate um but it was funnily enough
viable to sell for some massive amount
of auction to somebody with a various
ideas but the deal there was that the
lease holder operated the toilets they
were given a 21-year lease in exchange
for that um requirement as part of the
facility unfortunately losing the cafe
and you know let's assume that we've not
been Mis advised as to its uh you know
viability as a building means that those
toilets still sit there unus used and
unattended I think there's been a a
portter down there at one
point allowances rate Town counselors we
we pay good contribution towards the
cost of yeah I mean this is a busy Beach
very popular I know it doesn't suit
everyone's agenda but they ain't going
anywhere and and it's a 12mon beach as
well with the wild
swimmers given that the whole reason for
the debark and this festering derelict
block at the bottom of the cliff was
down to Southern Waters in ability to
provide a service should we not and
could we not please add to them that
there needs to be toilet provision there
until as I say there's an issue in that
the Block's been sold so is now in the
hands of a private individual who knows
where that will go but the the need for
toilet provision and it's and it's just
been lost in the process so um maybe
southern water would like to stump up
I'm sure sure it is not going to cost
them a vast sum in the scale of things
to stick for Port to L down there thank
you and uh or if not maybe we could move
the ones along that were put on the port
for the gypsies there's an idea for The
Travelers are they still there or have
they been removed now different subject
John no no I'm saying there were toilet
toilet provision was made there I think
we purchased some didn't
we yes there are there are toilets for
The Travelers yes are they given that
The Travelers have have come to the end
of their tenure could those toilets not
be relocated on that site so that they
provide provision for the beach
maybe so those toilets are there for The
Travelers I can't really comment on
moving those toilets there's no budget
for moving those toilets than putting
them permanently on on the on uh Western
Undercliff okay sorry to put you on the
spot but it's just struck me that there
is a solution here potentially at
minimal cost so perhaps we can read that
another occasion after the meeting okay
thank you Council
Austin I was going to raise um the same
question that Council Davis raised about
the Western Undercliff is it possible
for us at least to put the Western
undercliffe back onto the list as a
place that needs public toilet provision
even if we don't have a solution to that
at the moment we put two portaloos there
over the summer and they were very well
used and kept extraordinarily clean
there was no vandalism there was no
there wasn't so much much as you know a
shred of L roll down the beach or
anything they were really really well
used and responsibly used by the
extensive number of of swimmers and
families that use those beaches and we
really do need something a more
permanent solution of some kind so if we
can just please put put that that
location back on the list for future
consideration that would be a great help
thank
you yeah thank you councelor Austin and
and yeah understand the point completely
um it was tied up in the sale and the
agreement and that hasn't happened um I
think you we we have we have a budget
that we are working to in terms of
operating our public toilets um but the
report that I've referred to that will
be coming back next year I think yeah
it's um completely reasonable to refer
to those toilets and need um you know
need generally yeah need across the
district generally yeah thank you and
the last one C
scobby yes thank you chair um I just had
a couple of uh one quick comment and
then a request from the person I'm
subbing for counselor green um there's a
couple of comments just people asking
where the money comes for for public
toilets I just want to point out there's
a lot of council services that are
delivered at a loss um that's what
council tax is for um so this is one of
those toilets are a bit of an odd one
because it's not stat tree so it's
something we choose to do although in a
tourist Hotpot I don't think you can
call that any anything other than
absolutely essential so that was just
one comment shair um the point that um
councelor green asked me to raise and I
won't do uh a David Green impression I
say that for the bar afterwards um he
has just asked uh particularly with a
view to Ramsgate um the the reports on
toilets that are not going forward could
the committee have sight of those just
to understand some of the limitations
and some of the implications of that CU
if there's 27 that have been surveyed
this year and only a certain amount of
those going forward could the committee
uh see or could individual W counselor
see so that's David Green's comment not
mine did I not did not see a list in the
report where there some for future yeah
there's I'm pretty sure there's a list
there isn't
there yeah so just to be clear on what
we're talking about so so uh there are
two annexes one Annex talks about the
toilets we are doing and the cost of
those the other Annex um talks about the
revenue the pro the proposed for Revenue
repairs proposed for cap Capal repairs
and those that are proposed to happen in
another phase so that information is
there but are we talking about the
condition
survey right okay so I think yes I think
there's no reason why we can't make that
available yeah
yeah okay members uh recommendations
that we need to look at to Cabinet are
that cabinet approves the schedule of
works that this report suggests in
paragraph 3.1 and 3.2 either option one
or option two depending on the out of
the discussions with Southern water
which will be undertaken using £400,000
from funding of a marks reserves sorry
can you say again yeah can
can yeah I will start
again recommendations to Cabinet are the
cabinet approves the schedule of works
this report suggests in paragraph 3.1 St
3.2 either option one or option two
depending on the outcome of discussions
with Southern water which will be
undertaken you using £400,000 of funding
from earmark
reserves under option one 279,000 will
be allocated for Revenue repairs and
£21,000 revenue contribution to Capital
under option two the whole £400,000 will
be allocated to revenue repairs uh
£450,000 of capital funding via
borrowing and £400,000 from the Margate
Town deal funding external Grant
quite long-winded do we all agree to
that okay uh the next recommendation is
that cabinet recommends the council that
a one-off supplementary general fund
Revenue budget of £ 279,000 be approved
for the repairs to existing facilities
to be funded from an underspend
identified at the end of 2022 23 and
allocated to earmarked reserves for
investment in toilet facilities do we
all agree to that okay moving on to the
next one the cabinet endorses the
proposed financing of the existing 7
49,000 budget for the public toilets
refurbishment and renewal project within
the 200 20232 24 Capital program to be a
mix of £450,000 of borrowing
£21,000 contribution for ear Mar
reserves and financing of the remaining
£1
179,000 to be identified at a later date
with the actual financing of the capital
program being determined by the s151
officer as per officer delegations do we
all agree to that
lot of nodding heads uh next one that
cabinet recommends the council that a
supplementary general fund cabinet
capital budget of £250,000 be approved
for the refurbishment of existing boty
Bay toilets subject to the outcome of
discussions with Southern water for
funding to the value of £250,000
do we all agree to
that
okay that next one that cabinet approves
the budget vment adjustment to to be
made if discussions with Southern water
are not successful as per option two
with a varent of
£11,000 from the budget for the revenue
contribution to Capital be transferred
to the revenue budget for repairs to
existing
facilities do we all agree to that yeah
okay next one the cabinet notes that
£400,000 of approved capital budget is
allocated to toilet facilities within
the mgate town deal scheme in the 2022
23 to 24 Capital program three AG to
that and the last one that cabinet that
a further report taken to Cabinet before
the end of October
2224 sorry I'll start that again that a
further report taken to Cabinet before
the end of October 2024 which provides
an update on toilet refurbishment and
Improvement Works including the outcome
of the Southern water Financial
contribution the report shall also
propose the next steps to address the
refurbishment or improvements at the to
public toilets not included in this
initial phase do all agree to that okay
do we want to make any further
recommendations Council atin that we add
the Western Undercliff toilets to the
list please for future refurbishment or
future attention at least
consideration okay excellent uh any
further comments we want to make coun
scobby just just to clarify to council
Austin was that for future action or
consideration because you said both at
the end there I think it will need to be
consideration because we've got a an
agreement with a
private uh business so I think there has
to be consideration and then see what we
can do from there do you do you second
that Council SC I do not councelor gar
seconds there not because I disagree
with because I don't know enough about
it
okay second don't so I have to ask if
you all agree but you're probably
abstained from
that if there's no more recommendations
then can we all please note the
report okay that concludes the business
for tonight's meeting I'd like to thank
all the cabinet members and officers and
I I didn't introduce our monitor our new
monitor officer ingred so welcome to her
to the scrutiny and members of her team
as well and thank you all members for
coming along uh the live stream will now
end thank
you